This plot shows two of
our independent variables,
the number of office
visits on the x-axis
and the number of narcotics
prescribed on the y-axis.
Each point is an observation
or a patient in our data set.
The red points are patients
who received poor care,
and the green
points are patients
who received good care.
It's hard to see a
trend in the data
by just visually inspecting it.
But it looks like maybe
more office visits and more
narcotics, or data points
to the right of this line,
are more likely
to have poor care.
Let's see if we can build a
logistic regression model in R
to better predict poor care.
In our R console,
let's start by reading
our data set into R.
Remember to navigate
to the directory
on your computer
containing the file quality.csv.
We'll call our
data set "quality"
and use the read.csv function
to read in the data file
quality.csv.
Let's take a look
at the structure
of our data set by
using the str function.
We have 131 observations,
one for each
of the patients in our data
set, and 14 different variables.
MemberID just numbers the
patients from 1 to 131.
The 12 variables
from InpatientDays
to AcuteDrugGapSmall are
the independent variables.
We'll be using the
number of office visits
and the number of
prescriptions for narcotics
that the patient had.
But you can read
descriptions of all
of the independent
variables below this video.
After the lecture,
try building models
with different subsets
of independent variables
to see what the best model
is that you can find.
The final variable,
PoorCare, is our outcome
or dependent variable
and is equal to 1
if the patient had poor
care and equal to 0
if the patient had good care.
Let's see how many
patients received poor care
and how many patients
received good care
by using the table function.
Let's make a table of our
outcome variable PoorCare.
We can see that 98 out of the
131 patients in our data set
received good care, or 0, and
33 patients received poor care,
or those labeled with 1.
Before building any
models, let's consider
using a simple baseline method.
Last week when we
computed the R-squared
for linear regression, we
compared our predictions
to the baseline method of
predicting the average outcome
for all data points.
In a classification problem,
a standard baseline method
is to just predict the
most frequent outcome
for all observations.
Since good care is more common
than poor care, in this case,
we would predict
that all patients
are receiving good care.
If we did this, we
would get 98 out
of the 131 observations
correct, or have
an accuracy of about 75%.
So our baseline model
has an accuracy of 75%.
This is what we'll try to beat
with our logistic regression
model.
Last week, we always gave
you the training data set
and the testing data
set in separate files.
This week, we only
have one data set.
So we want to randomly split
our data set into a training set
and testing set so that
we'll have a test set
to measure our
out-of-sample accuracy.
To do this, we need to
add a new package to R.
There are many functions
and algorithms built into R,
but there are many more
that you can install.
We'll do this several times
throughout this course.
First, let's install
the new package using
the install.packages
function and then give
the name of the package we
want to install in quotes.
In this case, it's caTools.
If you hit Enter, a
window should pop up
asking you to pick
a CR AN mirror.
Here, you should pick
a location near you.
In my case, I'll
pick Pennsylvania
in the United States.
After you've
selected a location,
you should see some information
pop up in your R console.
It's done when you see the arrow
with the blinking cursor again.
Now, we need to load the package
into our current R session.
To do this, we'll use
the library function.
So type library and
then in parentheses
the name of our
package, caTools.
Sometimes you'll get
a warning message
based on the version
of R that you're using.
This can usually
safely be ignored.
In the future, whenever
you want to use a package,
you won't need to install it,
but you will need to load it.
Now, let's use this package
to randomly split our data
into a training set
and testing set.
We'll do this using a
function sample.split which
is part of the caTools package.
Since sample.split
randomly splits your data,
it could split it
differently for each of us.
To make sure that we all get the
same split, we'll set our seed.
This initializes the
random number generator.
So type set.seed(88),
a number I selected.
Now, let's use sample.split.
Type split =
sample.split, and then
in parentheses, we need
to give two arguments.
The first is our outcome
variable or quality$PoorCare,
and the second argument is the
percentage of the data that we
want in the training set.
We type SplitRatio
equals, and in this case,
we'll put 75% of the data in
the training set, which we'll
use to build the model, and
25% of the data in the testing
set to test our model.
Sample.split randomly
splits the data.
But it also makes sure
that the outcome variable
is well-balanced in each piece.
We saw earlier that
about 75% of our patients
are receiving good care.
This function makes sure
that in our training set,
75% of our patients
are receiving good care
and in our testing set
75% of our patients
are receiving good care.
We want to do this so that
our test set is representative
of our training set.
Let's take a look at split.
There is a TRUE or FALSE value
for each of our observations.
TRUE means that we should
put that observation
in the training
set, and FALSE means
that we should put that
observation in the testing set.
So now let's create our
training and testing
sets using the subset function.
We'll call our training
set qualityTrain
and use the subset function
to take a subset of quality
and only taking the
observations for which
split is equal to TRUE.
We'll call our testing
set qualityTest
and, again, use
the subset function
to take the
observations of quality,
but this time those for which
split is equal to FALSE.
If you look at the number of
rows in each of our data sets,
the training set and
then the testing set,
you can see that there are 99
observations in the training
set and 32 observations
in the testing set.
Now, we are ready to build
a logistic regression
model using OfficeVisits
and Narcotics
as independent variables.
We'll call our model QualityLog
and use the "glm" function
for "generalized
linear model" to build
our logistic regression model.
We start by giving
the equation we
want to build just like
in linear regression.
We start with the dependent
variable, and then
the tilde sign, and then
the independent variables
we want to use separated
by the plus sign.
We then give the
name of the data
set we want to use
to build the model,
in this case, qualityTrain.
For a logistic regression model,
we need one last argument,
which is family=binomial.
This tells the glm function
to build a logistic regression
model.
Now, let's look at our model
using the summary function.
The output looks similar to that
of a linear regression model.
What we want to focus on
is the coefficients table.
This gives the estimate
values for the coefficients,
or the betas, for our
logistic regression model.
We see here that the
coefficients for OfficeVisits
and Narcotics are
both positive, which
means that higher values
in these two variables
are indicative of
poor care as we
suspected from
looking at the data.
We also see that both
of these variables
have at least one star,
meaning that they're
significant in our model.
The last thing we want
to look at in the output
is the AIC value.
This is a measure of
the quality of the model
and is like Adjusted
R-squared in that it accounts
for the number of
variables used compared
to the number of observations.
Unfortunately, it
can only be compared
between models on
the same data set.
But it provides a means
for model selection.
The preferred model is the
one with the minimum AIC.
Now, let's make predictions
on the training set.
We'll call them predictTrain
and use the predict function
to make predictions using
the model QualityLog,
and we'll give a
second argument,
which is type="response".
This tells the predict function
to give us probabilities.
Let's take a look at
the statistical summary
of our predictions.
Since we're expecting
probabilities,
all of the numbers should
be between zero and one.
And we see that the
minimum value is about 0.07
and the maximum value is 0.98.
Let's see if we're predicting
higher probabilities
for the actual poor
care cases as we expect.
To do this, use the
tapply function,
giving as arguments predictTrain
and then QualityTrain$PoorCare
and then mean.
This will compute the
average prediction
for each of the true outcomes.
So we see that for all of
the true poor care cases,
we predict an average
probability of about 0.44.
And all of the true
good care cases,
we predict an average
probability of about 0.19.
So this is a good
sign, because it
looks like we're
predicting a higher
probability for the
actual poor care cases.
Now that we have our
model, in the next video,
we'll discuss how to assess the
accuracy of our predictions.